flowers for my Valentine appear to cry
fanfic today was the day now we're going
back on plans beauty was going to come
out and confess his love for cry with a
gift today was Valentine's Day and pity
was has been nervous the past few weeks
would cry a reject his gift and love or
will he's feel the same way pity side he
parked his car in Christ's driveway and
sat back in his seat he wasn't quite
sure if he was ready yet he glanced over
at the bouquet of flowers and picked
them up holding the flowers close to his
chest he wished himself luck and exited
the car
as he looked at cries house he saw the
front window curtains draw back and cry
was looking out when cry notice him he
smiled and waved oh and scurried all
over to answer the door
pitty walked up to the porch that before
he couldn't cry open the door and
practically pulled him in get him you
beauty what are you here
aren't you going to spend Valentine's
Day weekend cry notice the flowers and
pointed at them are those freaking
beautiful
oh no he thought for you cry was
astonished beauty what are you trying to
say I'm trying to say that I I really
liked you for a while now and the king I
may even have more feelings than like
and won't he be mad I mean sad I think I
love you cry open his mouth has to say
something but quickly shut it he studied
the baquette closer and took about what
whatever I'm sorry
okay closer and took it out of his hands
Hester deadly husband hesitantly I got
it
shut up okay Beauty I'm a fighter that I
really am but I have to ask about I left
can do mr. down at the floorboards
whirling his thumbs why would you leave
him you two were so happy together well
he seemed like P they looked up at cry
staring into his eyes I left there for
you I mean him Julie stepped closer to
crime grabbing the flowers and sitting
it down but somewhere nearby before
somewhere nearby Beauty took hold of
cries and before he could protest I had
a feeling I could be happier with you I
don't know if you even like me
I don't know even I don't know if you
even like men but I do know that every
time I look at you and every time I hear
your voice and that that I hope my
friend continued therapeutic his face
was flushed your red cry glanced down at
beauty's hands which were intertwined
with his beauty's dead packet
[Music]
Beauty I know you felt that way about me
before I I always push back my feelings
for you because of the same reason so so
all the time you beauty's world shield
off his own feelings and thought of
being reject only nerd knowledge cries
affection swartz him cry nodded a faint
smile on his face
you kept me waiting friends I'm sorry
oh and cry what is it
puny lean forward closer and closer to
cry zere cry will you be my Valentine
[Music]
of course beards of course cragger and
Link dearly in for a hug you had it
can I finish it go for he had a feeling
this was the start of a beautiful
relationship
[Music]